bisschen Zeit hier sehen Sie sie auch
auf der Regierungsbank schon auf diesen
Tag zu schauen also zunächst die
Befragung der Bundesregierung dann
erwartet Sie was Bärbel Bars gerade
schon als Zusatzpunkt genannt hat ab
ungefähr 15 Uhr 15 Uhr eine Aktuelle
Stunde zu den Protesten in Iran dann
gibt es im weiteren Verlauf des
Nachmittags auch noch ein
Entschließungsantrag der Unionsfraktion
da wird es nämlich darum gehen dass die
Unionsfraktion abstimmen lässt hier über
weitere Waffenlieferungen an die Ukraine
das dann am späteren Nachmittag
Frau Bundesministerin sie haben das Wort
für ihre einleitenden Ausführung
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
wir leben in einer Zeit multiplakriesen
die wirtschaftlichen sozialen Folgen von
corona-krieg Inflation Energie und
Klimakrise treffen auch die Menschen in
Deutschland wie unter einem Brennglas
ich bin froh in dieser Zeit Ministerin
einer Regierungs zu sein die notwendiges
tut und die klare Handlungsspielräume
sucht sie findet und dann auch nutzt
mein Ministerium ist das Ministerium für
Familie Senioren Frauen und Jugend das
heißt mein Ministerium steht für die
ganze Bandbreite unserer Gesellschaft
und wir haben all jene im Blick die
diesen diesen Krisen besonders stark
betroffen sind insbesondere auch im
dritten Entlastungspaket konnten wir
verankern dass Familien und Kinder ganz
besonders davon profitieren sie sind der
klare Schwerpunkt dieses Paketes
Familien bekommen ein höheres Kindergeld
von 237 Euro für das erste zweite und
dritte Kind und bekommt 250 Euro für das
vierte Kind
und auch mit der Einführung des
Bürgergeldes wird es zusätzlich für die
Familien die es besonders brauchen noch
zusätzliche Entlastungen geben eine
Erhöhung um 11,75 Prozent außerdem
steigen auch die Freibeträge für
zuverdienste von Schülerinnen
Studierenden Auszubildende auf 520 Euro
und nur einige Punkte zu nennen
heute im Kabinett
heute im Kabinett haben wir außerdem
eine Erhöhung und Verbreiterung des
Wohngeldes beschlossen damit werden nun
zukünftig statt unter einer Million zwei
Millionen Haushalte
bezugsberechtigt sein für das Wohngeld
und außerdem wird auch der
Heizkostenzuschuss deutlich erhöht
werden
das sind wichtige Bausteine hin zu einer
armuts Vermeidung in Deutschland das
zentrale Projekt darf in dieser
Legislaturperiode aus meinem Hause ist
aber die Kinder Grundsicherung und sie
wird einkommensschwache Familie
unterstützen weil es ein garantiebetrag
geben wird für alle Kinder unabhängig
von der Familienkonstellation und ein
einkommensabhängigen Zusatzbetrag
entsprechend des Einkommens
werte Abgeordnete Kinder haben konkret
in der Pandemie viel einstecken müssen
aber Kinder brauchen Zukunft und deshalb
haben wir in dem jetzt ja dem Bundestag
vorliegenden Haushalt 50 Millionen Euro
vorgesehen für ein zukunftspaket
Bewegung Kultur und Gesundheit womit wir
die Resilienz von Kindern und
Jugendlichen gezielt unterstützen wollen
vor allen Dingen aber auch ihre
Selbstwirksamkeit weil es sollen Kinder
und Jugendliche selber sein die darüber
bestimmen wie diese 50 Millionen Euro
verausgabt werden sollen
zu einem gesunden aufwachsen gehört aber
auch die frühkindliche Bildung von
Anfang an
Chancengerechtigkeit und darum bin ich
auch so froh dass es uns gelungen ist
dass kita-qualitätsgesetz auf den Weg zu
bringen vier Milliarden Euro zusätzlich
für die Länder für kita-qualität für
eine Verbesserung des
fachkraft-kindschlüssels für insgesamt
eine Verbesserung der Qualität der
Möglichkeiten für gesunde Ernährung
Bewegung und
Gesundheit aber vor allen Dingen für die
sprachliche Förderung von Anfang an
sie wissen dass
bundesmodellprogramm für sprach Kitas
läuft aus
das bundesmodell Programm für
sprachkitas war ein sehr erfolgreiches
Projekt es hat über elf Jahre lang alle
mitgenommen und gezeigt wie wichtig die
Spracherziehung bereits in der Kita ist
es ist rund um evaluiert ist von allen
Seiten als erfolgreich anerkannt und
deswegen ist jetzt eben der Zeitpunkt
die es in die Regelfinanzierung zu
überführen das sieht auch das
kita-qualitätsgesetz vor S1 der
zentralen Kriterien für die
kita-qualität ist die Sprachförderung
und deswegen setze ich mich dafür ein
dass wir es gemeinsam mit einer
hinkriegen vor allen Dingen setze ich
mich dafür ein dass wir auch zu einer
guten Übergangsregelung kommen mit den
Ländern
sie wissen es hakt noch aber ich bin
überzeugt wenn alles gemeinsam wollen
dann schaffen wir das es ist ganz
zentral wichtig dass die Fachkräfte von
uns ein klares Signal bekommen für eine
Weiterbeschäftigung dass sie nicht in
der Luft hängen und deswegen setze ich
mich
permanent inzwischen dafür ein dass wir
diesen Übergang gemeinsam hinbekommen
dafür braucht es aber auch eine
Bereitschaft der Länder
und dafür gibt es aber auch Signale von
diesem Hause zusätzliche Mittel zur
Verfügung zu stellen für diesen Übergang
aber lassen uns endlich zusammen an
einen Tisch kommen wir haben einfach
keine Zeit mehr
am Montag feiern wir den Tag der
Deutschen Einheit der dritte zehnte
erinnert uns an Sternstunden der
Demokratie an den Zusammenbruch einer
Diktatur und an den friedlichen Übergang
zu Demokratie im vereinten Deutschland
in einem geeinten Europa
aber auch 32 Jahre später ist Demokratie
nichts Selbstverständliches wie man an
so manchen Zwischenruf in diesem Hause
immer wieder feststellen muss es ist an
jeder und an jedem ein persönlichen
Beitrag zu leisten unsere Demokratie
mitzugestalten und zu stärken und wir
als Bundesregierung unterstützen all die
die sich zusammenschließen die etwas
dafür tun diese Demokratie zu
unterstützen und zu fördern und deswegen
bringen wir das demokratiefördergesetz
auf den Weg es befindet sich eine
Ressortabstimmung
das sind die wichtigsten Schwerpunkte
die ich hier mitteilen wollte und jetzt
freue ich mich auf Ihre Fragen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
vielen Dank wir beginnen die
regierungsbefragung zu den einleitenden
Ausführungen der Bundesministerin Frau
Lisa Paus und zum Geschäftsbereich sowie
zu den vorangegangenen Kabinettssitzung
und mit allgemeinen Fragen das Wort zur
ersten Frage hat aus der
cdu/csu-fraktion der Kollege Christoph
de Vries
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin Frau
Ministerin ich hätte mir ähnlich wie bei
ihrer Vorgängerin auch schon einen Satz
zum Kinderschutz in Deutschland
gewünscht dass es ausgeblieben deswegen
möchte ich Sie dazu Fragen die
bundesinnenministerin faesar hat im
Reaktion auf das Urteil gesagt das EuGH
für mich ist wichtig dass wir für die
Ermittlungsbehörden die IP-Adressen
verfügbar machen müssen der Europäische
Gerichtshof gibt uns diesen Spielraum
gerade die IP-Adressen zu speichern und
auch zu nutzen in ihrer Auffassung werde
sie auch von Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz
unterstützt ich frage sie als
Familienministerin und damit auch als
oberste kinderschützerin in Deutschland
unterstützen Sie das Vorhaben der
Innenministerin die IP-Adressen
Speicherung gesetzlich zu verankern zur
Ermittlungen und zur Strafverfolgung
damit jährlich tausende Fälle von
Kindesmissbrauch in Deutschland
aufgeklärt werden können
ich kann den versichern der Kinderschutz
hat oberste Priorität in dieser
Bundesregierung ich bin froh dass jetzt
mit dem EuGH-Urteil auch Klarheit noch
mal herrscht über das was wir können was
wir nicht können wir brauchen auf jeden
Fall eine Regelung auf europäischer
Ebene und auf nationaler Ebene das
Wissen das ist einfach deswegen
notwendig weil Europa leider zum
zentralen Hort von Bildern von Kindern
Missbrauch geworden ist und deswegen
müssen wir mit aller Klarheit auch
dagegen vorgehen sie wissen aber auch um
die Stellungnahme beispielsweise des
Bundesrates und deswegen müssen wir
natürlich den Kinderschutz gesetzlich so
absichern das ist dann auch endlich
dauerhaft Bestand hat
Vorratsdatenspeicherung war immer ihr
Lieblingsprojekt wir haben mehrfach
erleben müssen dass es eben kassiert
worden ist obwohl vom
Bundesverfassungsgericht als jetzt eben
auch vom EuGH von daher sind wir in der
ressoabstimmung zu einer guten Lösung
völlig klar ist der Kinderschutz hat
oberste Priorität aber private
chatkontrolle wird es nicht geben
können eine Nachfrage stellen vielen
Dank Frau Präsidentin ja gestern haben
wir auch die Innenminister einstimmig
sich für die Speicherung der IP-Adressen
ausgesprochen für eine verbindliche und
da sie die Frage nicht beantwortet haben
möchte ich Sie noch einmal wiederholen
sind Sie persönlich unterstützen sie die
bundesinnenministerin die das ja sehr
ausdrücklich getan hat in dem Ziel eine
Speicherpflicht IP-Adressen in
Deutschland gesetzlich zu verankern oder
nicht oder Favoriten favorisieren sie
andere Lösungen
wir sind dazu in der im Gespräch und ich
kann Ihnen sagen für mich hat
Kinderschutz oberste Priorität und die
Möglichkeiten die
verfassungsrechtlich möglich sind die
möchte ich da auch nutzen aber völlig
klar ist auch dass es eine anlasslose
massenüberwachung nicht geben kann
insbesondere nicht im Privaten
Chat-Bereich und genau diese
abgewogenheit glaube ich müssen wir
miteinander schaffen richtig ist aber
auch dass wir derzeit noch zu schlecht
sind beim Vollzug in der Breite dass wir
noch dass wir noch zusätzliche Dinge tun
können beispielsweise das Unternehmen
nicht nur melden sondern das Unternehmen
eben auch dann gleich löschen all diese
Dinge sind glaube ich wichtig und damit
können wir viel erreichen für den
Kinderschutz und das ist dringend
notwendig
[Applaus]
vielen Dank ich eröffne jetzt
die Frage Runde für Nachfragen zum
gleichen Thema ich will das nur noch mal
einmal sagen weil das schon mal ausufert
die Fragestellung es ging um den
Kinderschutz und IP-Adressen und als
nächstes hatte sich Frau mihalic
gemeldet
ganz herzlichen Dank Frau Präsidentin
Frau Ministerin Herr Kollege de Vries
ich will eingangs meiner Frage erst
einmal darauf hinweisen dass in Sachen
Vorratsdatenspeicherung IP-Adressen
Speicherung in der Zeit in der sie
dieses wunderbare Land regiert haben
rein gar nichts passiert ist was
irgendwie den Ermittlerin oder
Ermittlern hätte weiterhelfen können im
übrigen kann ich auch auf die
Vereinbarung Koalitionsvertrag hinweisen
und weil sie gestern die IMK
angesprochen haben auch die
Justizministerkonferenz also so
eindeutig wie sie das hier darstellen
war das Bild nicht aber was uns in
dieser Frage
selbstverständlich eint ist ja das worum
es im Kern geht wie können Kinder oder
natürlich auch andere vor solchen
schrecklichen Verbrechen geschützt
werden was kann eigentlich ganz konkret
getan werden Frau Ministerin sie haben
vorhin in ihrer Antwort schon ein paar
Andeutungen gemacht vielleicht können
Sie das noch ein bisschen näher
ausführen was in Fragen des
Kinderschutzes hier für uns alle von so
finanzieller Bedeutung ist
Frau Ministerin
Hintergrund ist ja dass es einen
Richtlinienentwurf gibt von der
Europäischen Kommission die wesentliche
Verbesserung erreichen würde für den
Kinderschutz zum Beispiel eine Plattform
auf europäischer Ebene zum Beispiel
zusätzliche
gesetzliche Regelungen das eben
Unternehmen nicht nur melden sondern
dass sie eben dann auch direkt löschen
das wäre ein großer großer Vortritt in
diesen Bereich damit eben diese Bilder
diese furchtbaren Bilder von
Kindesmissbrauch aus dem Netz schnell
verschwinden
sie möchten keine Nachfrage mehr stellen
dann habe ich jetzt die Kollegen breher
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin Frau
Ministerin juristisch ist es geklärt die
Speicherung von IP-Adressen ist möglich
und da sie die Frage meines Kollegen
noch nicht beantwortet haben frage ich
sie noch einmal Sie persönlich sind sie
für die Speicherung der IP-Adressen wie
des europäische Recht ist zulässt ja
oder nein
sehr geehrte Frau Abgeordnete es ist im
juristisch nicht alles geklärt darauf
wurde ja gerade schon hingegeben es gibt
unterschiedliche Einschätzungen sowohl
der
Justizminister als auch der
Innenminister vor allen Dingen geht es
ja darum wie man es einstuft ja ich bin
der Meinung dass
Kindes Bilder von kindesmissbraucht dass
das schwere Verbrechen sind und in dem
Zusammenhang muss man dann noch mal
prüfen wie man insgesamt damit umgeht
aber es geht da nicht einfach nur so um
die Speicherung von IP-Adressen und es
geht ja um den ganzen Reigen in den
Zusammenhang und für mich ist klar eine
private chatkontrolle darf es nicht
geben
geh davon aus keine Nachfrage mehr oder
zum Thema Kinderschutz
IP-Adressen noch mal hätte Fries sie
hatten eigentlich schon die Frage
hast zulassen aber es sind ja auch
andere Möglichkeiten ein Spiel gebracht
worden mit dem Urteil umzugehen und
deswegen Frau Ministerin sie sagten sie
sind in der Koalition damit im Gespräch
was halten Sie denn von dem unterstützen
von dem favorisierten Verfahren von
Herrn Justizminister Buschmann dem
sogenannten quick freeze mit dem man
Daten nachträglich sichern will die gar
nicht gespeichert worden sind weil er
keine Speicherpflicht möchte wie
bewerten sie das
auch dazu auch dazu sind wir noch in der
Abstimmung die fachliche Bewertung ist
noch bei mir jedenfalls nicht
vollständig abgeschlossen
wir sind immer noch beim Kinderschutz
IP-Adressen und dann habe ich jetzt noch
eine Nachfrage der Kollegin aus der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
es ist schon lang ja vielen Dank erstmal
möchte ich darauf hinweisen dass wir die
Bundesfamilienministerin befragen und
deswegen würde ich auch gern fragen
wollen liebe Lisa Paus was wie sie im
Bereich Prävention Vorhaben auch gerade
in Bezug auf die ubs-km da stehen ja
einige Veränderungen an
herzlichen Dank für die Frage sie haben
völlig recht weil Kinderschutz zwar ein
Priorität in dieser Koalition hat wollen
wir gemeinsam ein Gesetz auf den Weg
bringen was den Kinderschutz noch einmal
verstärkt ein zentraler Bestandteil
dessen ist dass du jetzt in diesem
Herbst noch mal eine Kampagne machen
wollen zum Thema tatsächlich Prävention
und insgesamt bin ich der Auffassung das
grundsätzlich Förderung von
verschiedensten Einrichtungen wenn eben
Kinder und Jugendliche sich in diesen
Einrichtungen befinden dass es immer mit
schutzkonzepten einhergehen sollte das
sollten wir als Bundes von der
Bundesebene vorangehen aber es gilt
natürlich auch für entsprechende
Maßnahmen von Kommunen und Ländern das
sollte Standard werden das Förderung und
Schutzkonzepte für Kinder und
Jugendliche Hand in Hand gehen müssen
vielen Dank ich gehe jetzt weiter in der
Liste der
Fragestellerin und als nächstes ist die
Kollegin Josefine Ortlepp an der Reihe
aus der SPD-Fraktion
denn dank frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte
Frau Ministerin während wir hier stehen
versuchen abtreibungsgegnerinnen Frauen
in
Konfliktsituationen im Süden
Deutschlands daran zu hindern diese
Beratungsstellen
Schwangerschaftsberatungsstellen zu
besuchen wir sind der Meinung Frauen
haben ein Recht auf einen sicheren
anonymen und ungehinderten Zugang zu
diesen Beratungsstellen gerade weil sie
ja verpflichtet sind diese Beratungen
Anspruch zu nehmen wir sehen einen
dringenden gesetzlichen Handlungsbedarf
daher die Frage an Sie wir stehen sie
wie steht ihr Haus dazu und was haben
sie da vor vielen Dank
auch ich sehe da Handlungsbedarf es
handelt sich dabei ja um sogenannte
gehsteigbelästigungen das hat mit
Demonstrationen Demonstrationsrecht so
erstmal nichts zu tun sondern es geht ja
um Bedrohung von den Personen die eben
die entsprechenden Einrichtungen auch
suchen wollen deswegen müssen wir das
klar Abtrennen von dem natürlich
bestehenden demonstrations also von der
Demonstrationsfreiheit in Deutschland
aber wenn es eben darum geht direkt
Menschen zu bedrohen dann ist das nicht
okay und dann ist das auch mehr als
nicht okay dann ist das aus meiner Sicht
eben tatsächlich
etwas was wir ernten sollten und
deswegen arbeiten wir einer neuen
gesetzlichen Regelung dass so etwas dann
auch eine Ordnungswidrigkeit wird
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
vielen Dank das ist gut zu wissen dass
wir da gemeinsam kämpfen für mich wenn
nur noch die Nachfrage ob es da schon
zeitlichen Horizont gibt weil wie gesagt
es ist wirklich dringend Frauen in
Deutschland sind im Moment daran
gehindert diese Beratungsstellen zu
besuchen
also wir sind wir sind zügig dabei ich
würde sagen das damit können Sie in
diesem Jahr noch rechnen
zum gleichen Thema habe ich zwei
Nachhang dem Moment zuerst die Kollegin
Frau von Storch dran
vielen Dank er kann sie vielleicht
einmal beschreiben inwieweit Frauen
gehindert werden eine Beratungsstelle
aufzusuchen wenn sie am Bordstein
angesprochen werden um auf irgendetwas
hingewiesen zu werden
insoweit wird kriminalisiert das Reden
mit einer Frau die einen bestimmten Ort
aufsuchen will können Sie das mal
beschreiben wie man das unter
Ordnungswidrigkeiten überhaupt fassen
kann oder ob das ein ganz normaler
Vorgang ist der sich jeden Tag
millionenfach auf der Straße eignet
jemand spricht jemanden anderen an
Frau von Stolz ich kann mir vorstellen
dass sie an einer entsprechenden Aktion
vielleicht schon mal teilgenommen haben
alles was ich darüber weiß erfahren
musste ist eben leider dass es nicht
einfach ein nettes Gespräch ist und eine
nette Nachfrage nach dem Weg oder
ähnliches sondern dass es eben sehr oft
lautstark und extrem eskaliert und es
ist eben so dass von diesen
Einrichtungen berichtet wird die ja
oftmals auch nicht einfach nur
Schwangeren abspruchberatungsstellen
sind sondern oftmals auch eine Vielzahl
von Angeboten haben dass Menschen sich
eben nicht mehr in dieser Einrichtungen
trauen und so und von daher ist das
Tatbestand der der Bedrohung glaube ich
durchaus
durchaus existent und deswegen finde
dieses mindestens angezeigt eine
Ordnungswidrigkeit in diesem
Zusammenhang zu verhängen
[Applaus]
nächsten Frage stellt die Kollegin
schaus Bündnis 90 die Grünen
vielen Dank Frau Ministerin auch noch
mal für die sehr klare Antwort gerade
auf die Frage die sich wirklich nicht
nachvollziehen lässt heute ist wer das
nicht weiß der 28.09 der sogenannte
safe-botion day also der Tag der
sicheren Schwangerschaftsabbrüche und
das ist in der Tat mit Belästigung aber
auch Betenden Gruppen vor
Beratungsstellen eben so dass eben
diejenigen die die Beratungsstellen
aufsuchen müssen sich eben tatsächlich
belästigt oder vielleicht bedroht und
eingeschüchtert fühlen und wie gesagt es
gibt hier auch einige Menschen in diesem
Haus auf der rechten Seite die an diesen
glaube ich Versammlungen schon
teilgenommen haben deswegen die Frage
noch mal an sie Frau Ministerin sie
haben gerade schon auch den Zeithorizont
genannt es gibt bisher ja keine Regelung
dass die Länder dem folgen müssen können
sie noch mal sagen warum es so wichtig
ist dass Sie eine bundeseinheitliche
Regelung jetzt sehr schnell vorlegen wir
sind sehr froh dass sie das tun aber
vielleicht können sie noch mal sagen
warum das so wichtig ist für die Länder
und was es letztendlich für die
aufsuchenden
Rat kommenden bedeutet danke
die stabbelästigung ist ja leider eben
kein ganz neues Phänomen und es hat sich
eben gezeigt dass es also aus meiner
Sicht hat sich gezeigt dass es eben
notwendig ist das einheitliche
bundesweit auch klar zu regeln weil es
eben auch Unsicherheiten gibt und gab
über die Anwendung über die Situation
auch insbesondere die Abgrenzung oder
die Verhältnis zum Thema
Demonstrationsrecht und deswegen finde
ich ist es einfach angezeigt diese
Klarheit zu schaffen indem wir das als
Ordnungswidrigkeit einstufen
nächste Frage zum gleichen Thema die
Kollegin Katja Mast aus der SPD-Fraktion
vielen Dank zuerst mal Frau Ministerin
dass sie so klar gesagt haben dass wir
im Laufe dieses Jahres des Regeln können
weil diese Initiative vor die days for
Life nennt sie sich ist eine weltweite
Initiative und die steht dann in einem
halben Jahr wieder an der gleichen
Stelle 40 Tage lang und deshalb ist doch
die Botschaft von heute nicht noch mal
40 Tage insofern freue ich mich ganz
besonders über diese Äußerung ich finde
nur wichtig und es wäre dann auch meine
Frage in meinem Wahlkreis in Pforzheim
stehen da auch regelmäßig vor der pro
familia Beratungsstelle die diese
Initiative aktuell an der vierspurigen
Straße gegenüber und ich finde nicht nur
wichtig zu berücksichtigen ob die Frauen
angesprochen werden sondern dass sie
ohne
dass sie erkannt werden können ohne
beobachtungsgefühl ohne Stigmatisierung
durch Gebete Gesänge oder Plakate
ihren ihrer Pflicht letztendlich
Nachkommen die wir Ihnen ja aufgegeben
haben in die 218 Beratungsstelle zu
gehen und deshalb ist meine Frage ob sie
glauben dass wir das auch so regeln
können dass weder angemeldete
Gottesdienste noch Demonstration noch
Einzelpersonen sich dauerhaft in
unmittelbarer Nähe zu solchen
Beratungsstellen oder auch zu Arztpraxen
aufhalten können weil das findet gerade
aktuell in Stuttgart statt
[Applaus]
weisen da auch weitere wichtige
Realitäten die wir in Deutschland haben
hin deswegen glaube ich werden wir das
im Zuge der Beratung nur zu diesem
Gesetz zu der Ordnungswidrigkeit dann
miteinander klären müssen ob es dann
auch im Mindestabstände geht oder um
anderes all das werden wir dann
miteinander im Verfahren klären denke
ich
vielen Dank noch mal eine Ansage zur
Zeit es sollten hier keine Statements
oder reden abgegeben werden sondern
einzelne Fragen dann bitte ich noch mal
drauf zu achten sonst kommen wir mit
dieser Fragestunde nicht durch
die nächste zum Thema ist die Kollegin
Reicheneck aus der Fraktion DIE LINKE
ja jetzt vielen Dank für die Gelegenheit
Frau Ministerin und ich freue mich auch
sehr über Ihre Aussagen bezüglich der
gehsteigbelästigung das ist ein sehr
wichtiges Thema wir sind gerade im
Kontakt mit unseren GenossInnen der
Linksfraktion in Hessen da ist das
Problem dass die dortige schwarz-grüne
Regierung gerne auf den Bund zeigt der
dann wiederum auf die Länder zeigt wie
können sie denn garantieren dass diese
Regelung die sie jetzt erarbeiten dann
auch wirklich umgesetzt wird also ist da
was in Planung dass dieses Ping Pong
nicht weitergeht und ergänzend würde ich
gerne Fragen danke für den Verweis auf
den Safe Burschen der der ist sehr
wichtig und richtig und gut dass das
jetzt noch mal alle wissen wir haben ja
auch noch das große Problem von
Paragraph 218 der ja auch noch weg muss
das haben sie jetzt in eine Kommission
vertagt als Koalition wie ist denn da
der Umsetzungsstand wann wird die sich
denn konstituieren und wann geht es
richtig los vielen Dank
[Applaus]
also wenn sich eine ich fange mit der
ersten Frage an wenn sich hier in eine
Mehrheit im Deutschen Bundestag findet
das zu einer Ordnungswidrigkeit zu
machen und entsprechenden
Bedingungen dann ist es meines Wissen
nicht zustimmungspflichtig im Bundesrat
und würde damit dann eben tatsächlich in
Deutschland insgesamt gelten und zum
Thema Expertenkommission das da haben
sie darauf richtig darauf hingewiesen
das haben wir in der Koalition im
Koalitionsvertrag miteinander vereinbart
wir sind da auch schon sehr sehr weit
wir sind uns schon weitgehend einig über
den Arbeitsauftrag dieser Kommission sie
wissen er hat zwei Komponenten das eine
ist noch mal darum den
§ 218 aus dem welche Möglichkeiten es
gibt ihn aus dem Strafgesetzbuch
herauszunehmen auf der anderen Seite
geht es eben auch um das Thema
Leihmutterschaft und allzellspende wir
sind in den schlussberatungen und ich
bin auch sehr zuversichtlich dass ich in
Kürze Ihnen die entsprechende Kommission
vorstellen kann die eine
Sachverständigenkommission sein wird
vielen Dank bevor ich den nächsten
Fragesteller Aufrufe Frau von Storch sie
haben gerade Kindermörder reingerufen
und dafür erteile ich Ihnen einen
Ordnungsruf
ich erteile Ihnen für diesen Begriff ein
ordnungshof Niemand ist ja ein
Kindermörder und die Kollegin schon gar
nicht
und als nächster Fragesteller habe ich
den Herrn Brandner und auch wenn das
Thema
sehr wichtig ist und auch emotional
bitte ich auf die Wortwahl zu achten
jetzt Herr Brandner dürfen Sie Ihre
Frage stellen tue ich immer also ich
sage nichts ganz ganz wenig nur
unbedachten vor allem wenn sie dabei
sind also ich bewunder ihre Kreativität
wenn es darum geht neue
Ordnungswidrigkeiten Tatbestände zu
schaffen weil sich irgendwelche Frauen
die durch vierspurige Straßen von einer
Menschengruppe beobachtet werden ja
bedrängt fühlen finde ich erstaunlich
und wünschte mir so eine Kreativität
auch mal wenn sie so gegen Öko
Terroristen vorgehen würden die sich
also stundenlang auf Straßenfest kleben
und wichtige Infrastruktur blockieren
aber da ist ja der Fantasie nicht Türen
Tor geöffnet also wir machen Sie da auch
noch irgendwas meine Frage geht noch mal
zur zum Abtreibung an sich 218 218a 219
219a ist ja abgeschafft die wollen das
Gesamtgefüge abschaffen 218 abschaffen
bis zu welchem Schwangerschaftsmonat
schwebt Ihnen den Straffreiheit für ein
Schwangerschaftsabbruch vor
Herr Brandner ich habe gerade schon
darauf hingewiesen dass diese
Bundesregierung sich darauf verständigt
hat eine Sachverständigenkommission
einzuberufen das wird auch in Kürze
erfolgen die ist in der Federführung des
Bundesgesundheitsministeriums mein Haus
und das Bundesjustizministerium sind
auchs daran beteiligt da werden wir
sprechen darüber inwieweit der 218
obwieweit ist weiter sinnvoll ist das
Thema mit 218 im Strafgesetzbuch zu
regeln oder ob es nicht auch andere
Möglichkeiten gibt und das andere Thema
was in dieser Kommission erarbeitet
werden soll ist das Thema
Leihmutterschaft und Eizellspende und
auf der Grundlage dieser fachlichen
Beratung durch diese Sachverständigen
werden wir dann das ganze evaluieren da
werde ich dem nicht vorgreifen
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen 30
Sekunden ach ich brauche nur fünf
Sekunden mich persönlich interessiert
Ihre persönliche aufweisung was schwebt
Ihnen davor bis zu welchem
Schwangerschaftsmonat sollte
Schwangerschaftsabbruch Abtreibung
straflos sein
ich habe schon darauf hingewiesen ich
greife dieser Arbeit der
Sachverständigenkommission nicht vor ich
bin allerdings der Meinung dass die
Regelung im Strafgesetzbuch keine gute
ist weil es eben derzeit so ist dass
diese Regelungen Frauen stigmatisiert
und kriminalisiert und deswegen glaube
ich dass im Jahr 2022 es sinnvoll ist im
Rahmen einer Sachverständigenkommission
das noch mal zu erörtern und
gegebenenfalls zu anderen Regelungen zu
kommen ich finde es hat eigentlich im
Strafgesetzbuch nicht zu suchen
ich gehe zur nächsten angemeldeten Frage
aus der afd-fraktion Martin Reichert
ja Frau Ministerin wir haben in
Deutschland seit Jahrzehnten ein extrem
niedriges Geburtenniveau wir haben 1,4
Kinder pro Frau das führt dazu dass von
der Elterngeneration zur nächsten
Elterngeneration die Generation um
ungefähr 25 Prozent plus das eine oder
andere kleiner wird und das passiert
obwohl das passiert obwohl wir wissen
dass der Kinderwunsch bei jungen
Menschen höher ist das passiert auch
deswegen weil man erkennen muss dass
auch Menschen mit Migrationshintergrund
die gut integriert sind sich dieser
dieser Geburtenzahl annähern wir haben
also ein gesellschaftliches und
systemisches Problem und ich möchte
Ihnen hier die Frage stellen zum ersten
was tun Sie um die Menschen in
Deutschland aufzuklären über die
verheerenden Folgen der demografischen
Katastrophe die nämlich im Bereich der
Rentenversicherung im Bereich der
Sozialversicherung im nicht der
Gesundheitsvorsorge vorhanden sind und
zweitens was tun Sie um diese ganze
Entwicklung dieser ganzen Entwicklung
gegen entgegenzuwirken und eine kräftige
kinderfreundliche Politik zu machen denn
das was sie bisher genannt haben zum
Beispiel die Vereinbarkeit von Familie
und Beruf sind hier erkennbar ja völlig
insuffizient
Frau Ministerin
Herr Abgeordneter ich habe mich
tatsächlich seit vielen Jahren intensiv
mit den entsprechenden Thesen
beschäftigt und ich kann Ihnen sagen
dass wenn sich das mal statistisch
anschauen dass dort wo es in westlichen
Ländern eine besonders konservative
Haltung gibt zum Thema Familie und zum
Thema Rolle der Frau und zum Thema Frau
muss irgendwie gebären mindestens so und
so viel Kinder in dieser Zeit exakt das
Gegenteil funktioniert passiert sondern
die Wahrheit ist
die Wahrheit ist Frauen lassen sich das
im zweiten 21 Jahrhundert nicht mehr
gefallen sondern Frauen wollen
selbstbestimmt leben können und es geht
eben darum gute Rahmenbedingungen für
die Vereinbarkeit von Familie und Beruf
zu schaffen und da können wir uns zum
Beispiel die skandinavischen Länder
anschauen
die das in der Tat noch besser
hinkriegen als wir und dann stellen wir
auch fest wenn es eben entsprechende
soziale Infrastruktur geht wenn eben
gewährleistet ist das ist eine gute
frühkindliche Erziehung gibt weil in den
Kindertagesstätten und auch
Ganztagsschulen und Eltern mit gutem
Gewissen ihre Kinder in die
entsprechenden Einrichtungen geben und
eben Vereinbarkeit von Familie und Beruf
leben können dann steigen die
entsprechenden Geburtenraten wir haben
einiges auch Vorgängerregierung einiges
gemacht zum Beispiel das Elterngeld zum
Beispiel den Ausbau von
Kindertagesstätten und von
Ganztagsbetreuung in den Schulen in den
Grundschulen aber da ist noch einiges
Luft nach oben wenn wir gute Bedingungen
hinkriegen für die Vereinbarkeit dann
werden auch die Geburtenraten steigen
ein Zwang zur Geburt ist wirklich
abwegig das wüsste ich auch nicht wie
das auf dem Grund auf dem Boden unseres
Grundsätze in irgendeiner Art und Weise
denkbar wäre
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
Frau Ministerin also zunächst mal möchte
ich Ihnen folgendes sagen also ihre
offensichtlich aus ihrer ideologischen
Blase stammenden
Äußerungen wir würden einen Zwang zur
Geburt wollen sind natürlich völliger
Unsinn und die weise ich hier auch in
aller Schärfe zurück es geht darum es
geht darum dass die geeigneten Maßnahmen
geschaffen werden und das auch eine
Sensibilisierung eben bei den Menschen
im Land stattfindet es muss den Menschen
doch klar gesagt werden dass das
Anhalten der gegenwärtigen geboten
Situation eben auf allen politischen
Ebenen insbesondere Renten
Sozialversicherung etc verheerende
Auswirkungen hat und da frage ich sie
noch mal die Frage haben sie nicht
beantwortet sie betreiben zum Beispiel
im Bereich des der Klimapolitik eine
Panikmache weisen aber auf die größte
Katastrophe und das größte Problem was
wir in Deutschland haben nicht einmal
hin sondern versuchen das immer
abzuwiegeln
Frau Ministerin
weder Mutter Pflicht noch Mutterkreuz
ist da die Lösung
wenn wir uns eben anschauen ich hatte
schon darauf hingewiesen Geburtenraten
in Japan beispielsweise Geburtenraten in
Italien Geburtenraten in Spanien überall
da wo es eben eher ein konservatives
patriarchales Familienbild gibt haben
sie sinkende Geburtenraten und keine
steigenden Geburtenraten deswegen kommt
es auf die Vereinbarkeit an daran
arbeite ich in der Tat mit Hochdruck und
kann auch darauf verweisen dass im
Moment übrigens die Geburtenraten
tatsächlich auch leicht steigen
zum gleichen Thema gibt es dazu
Nachfragen ich sehe eine Nachfrage aus
der FDP-Fraktion
vielen Dank Frau Ministerin das zeigt ja
dass wir gerade um die den
demokratischen demografischen Wandel
aufzuhalten gute und ausreichend
Kitaplätze brauchen und da hat ja auch
die Ampelkoalition jetzt mit dem
kita-qualitätsgesetz ein wichtiges
Gesetz auf den Weg gebracht mit vier
Milliarden Investitionen
wie läuft denn da im Augenblick der
Mittelabruf dieses Programms um eben
nicht nur gute und qualitätvolle
Kitaplätze zu gewährleisten sondern eben
auch ja bei dem
kita-investitionsprogramm mehr Plätze zu
gewährleisten
der Mittelabfluss ist wirklich gut und
ich kann sagen dass damit eben unter
anderem ermöglicht wurde das zusätzliche
90.000 Kitaplätze in Deutschland
geschaffen wurden durch diese
Unterstützung von dem Mund
vielen Dank
ich habe noch eine Nachfrage zum Thema
Kinderwunsch Geburtenzahlen aus der
afd-fraktion
vielen Dank Frau Ministerin Paus wir
haben unwidersprochen eine
demografischkrise das geht auch an die
Fraktion der Linken deswegen mal kurz
anmerken mit der Demografie schrumpft
auch der Anteil der Erwerbstätigen und
das führt unmittelbar zu einem
Fachkräftemangel und natürlich hat das
auch Einfluss auf die Rentenkassen nicht
also es ist ja völlig klar mehr
Rentenbezieher weniger Einzahler gibt
ein Problem
wenn wir das wie es insbesondere die FDP
vorhat über Zuwanderung lösen wollen
lösen wir das natürlich nicht an der
Ursache Zuwanderung kommt von außen die
Ursache liegt hier im Land das ist also
eine symptomatische Herangehensweise ich
möchte an der Stelle mal das Institut
für Arbeitsmarkt und berufsforschung mit
Erlaubnis der Präsidenten zitieren dort
heißt es kann die Annahme gemäß konstant
bleibende jährliche Zuwanderung den
demografischen Effekt zunehmend weniger
kompensieren andere Institute sagen die
Kompensation ist sogar ausgeschlossen
welche Lösungsmöglichkeiten
schwimm ihn vor zu dem Thema
also Moment zum Beispiel haben wir doch
relativ viele neue MitbürgerInnen unter
uns und aus der Ukraine weil sie eben
leider fliehen mussten vor dem Krieg den
wir in der Ukraine haben von daher ist
es im Moment jetzt nicht so dass wir
jetzt niemanden da hätten gleichzeitig
ist es so dass wir eben als
Bundesregierung erarbeiten an der
Fachkräfte Offensive und immer allein
denjenigen helfen würden die hier sind
die hier sind und die sehr gute
Abschlüsse haben aber immer noch
darunter leiden dass wir es in
Deutschland hinbekommen qualifizierte
Abschlüsse gleiche Abschlüsse
entsprechend anzuerkennen dann wären wir
schon einen großen Schritt weiter denn
das ist jetzt nur eine Maßnahme die wir
angehen wie ich ihn jetzt hier
präsentiere aber sie wissen wir arbeiten
insgesamt daran es gibt die Fachkräfte
Offensive die Strategie wird
federführend koordiniert von meinem
Kollegen Hubertus Heil zusammen mit
Robert Habeck dem Wirtschaftsminister
und der Bundesbildungsministerin und wir
werden einiges tun dafür dass wir eben
tatsächlich die Fachkräfte die wir hier
haben sichern und weiter unterstützen
und einsetzen können und zusätzlich
Fachkräfte gewinnen für diesen
Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland er hat
es wirklich kann es sehr sehr gut
gebrauchen
[Applaus]
ich habe noch eine Nachfrage aus der
Fraktion Die Linke die Kollegin Gökay
vielen Dank ich habe auch eine Frage zum
Thema Vereinbarkeit Berufung Familie
Frau Ministerin letzte Woche wurde von
der EU ein Vertragsverletzungsverfahren
gegen Deutschland eingeleitet wegen der
Nichtumsetzung der Richtlinie zu
Vereinbarkeit von Beruf und Privatleben
die Richtlinie garantiert dem zweiten
Elternteil einen bezahlten Urlaub von
mindestens zehn Tagen nach der Geburt
eines Kindes welche Maßnahmen will die
Bundesregierung ergreifen um diesen
Rechtsanspruch auch umzusetzen
sie haben Recht wir haben diesen Brief
erhalten es macht es nicht besser aber
wir waren nicht die einzigen die diesen
Brief erhalten haben was es besser macht
ist dass wir dieses Gesetz ja
tatsächlich die Umsetzung der Richtlinie
bereits vor der Sommerpause vom Kabinett
verabschiedet haben und sie inzwischen
in Bundestag vorliegt und das jetzt den
normalen Beratung entspricht und wir
haben entsprechende Zeit dass in dem
zeitlichen Rahmen dann umzusetzen und
dann hat sich das
Vertragsverletzungsverfahren auch in
Luft aufgelöst
möchten Sie noch eine Nachfrage stellen
ja und zwar die die Zahlen der
Inanspruchnahme von Elterngeld durch
Vätern sind konstant niedrig geblieben
in den letzten Jahren hier in
Deutschland das sind etwa 33 Prozent
aller Väter die überhaupt das in
Anspruch nehmen und die Einführung eines
bezahlten Urlaubs würde aber die
Partnerschaftlichkeit bei der Erziehung
und nach der Geburt der Kinder in so
einer schwierigen Phase viel besser
Stärken wie will die Bundesregierung die
stärkere Nutzung von Elterngeld durch
den zweiten Elternteil vorantreiben um
die Gleichstellung von Eltern auch zu
verbessern
sie haben völlig Recht dass es ein
wichtiger Bestandteil ist für die
bessere Vereinbarkeit in der Familie
dass man auch gleich von Anfang an
gemeinsam dabei ist nicht nur bei der
Geburt sondern eben insbesondere auch
bei der intensiven Phase in der ersten
und zweiten Woche nach der Geburt
deswegen haben wir das ja auch im
Koalitionsvertrag verankert und sind
dazu auch in der in der Ressort
Befassung
ich
das war's ja sie durften nur eine
Nachfrage stellen
ich würde gerne in der Liste weitergehen
wenn das möglich ist
die nächste Fragestellerin wäre Ulle
schaust
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin
Frau Ministerin
geschlechtsspezifische Gewalt und auch
menschenhandel ist leider immer noch
furchtbare Realitäten in diesem Land und
auch nicht nur in diesem Land deswegen
gibt es die istanbul-konvention und die
Umsetzung der ist Konvention ist auch
ein sehr wichtiges Anliegen der
Regierung das Recht auf Schutz vor
Gewalt muss für Frauen und Kinder für
alle vulnerablen Gruppen vorbehaltlos
gelten ein wichtiger Teil davon ist die
monitoringstelle zur Beobachtung
Begleitung und Bewertung der Umsetzung
der istanbul-konvention wir hatten
gerade heute im Ausschuss dazu auch eine
Aussprache mit den entsprechenden
Institutionen und es ist auch ein
wichtiger Teil der
europarechtskonvention gegen den
Menschenhandel können Sie uns sagen wann
die Berichterstatter stellen ihre Arbeit
aufnehmen und wann die Aufgaben auch bei
der Umsetzung der istanbul-konvention
von der berichterstattestelle in welcher
Form übernommen werden
sie haben Recht die istanbul-konvention
ist ganz ganz entscheidend um nicht nur
aufmerksam zu machen sondern auch Schutz
zu verankern in den allen Schaden die
das unterzeichnet haben Deutschland ist
auch in Unterzeichner Land auch bei uns
gibt es aber auch noch das eine oder
andere sozusagen zusätzlich umzusetzen
diese Arbeit der solchen Instituts für
Menschenrechte liefer jetzt schon etwas
länger ist jetzt gut vorbereitet und wir
die berichterstattungsstellen die zwei
zum einen für das Thema
geschlechtsspezifisch Gewalt aber auch
für Menschenhandel die werden jetzt
aktuell konkret eingerichtet so dass
dann jetzt tatsächlich all diejenigen
davon betroffen sind sich auch an dieser
Stelle wenden können damit wir eben auch
noch bessere Datengrundlagen haben aber
vor allen Dingen eben auch konkret
Abhilfe schaffen können darüber hinaus
erarbeiten mein Haus auch ist auch ein
Koalitionsvertrag verankert eine
bundesgesetzliche Regelung zur
Absicherung des Schutzes gegen
geschlechtliche
geschlechtsspezifische Gewalt und gegen
häusliche Gewalt dazu wird es unter
anderem im November einen runden Tisch
geben mit den Ländern aber auch mit den
entsprechenden Fachverbänden damit wir
endlich bei der gesetzlichen Regelung
dann auch einen großen Schritt
vorankommen
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
ja vielen Dank dass es eine gute
Nachricht dass es jetzt weitergeht und
der weitere Verlauf auch für die
istanbul-konvention gibt es ja auch
weitere Schritte zum Beispiel auch die
Koordinierungsstelle die jetzt auch im
Koalitionsvertrag verankert wurde
was ist das spezielle auch was sie auch
im Haus jetzt vorantreiben werden es
geht ja um eine ressortübergreifende
Umsetzung der istanbul-konvention also
mit welchen Häusern werden sie auch da
zum Thema istanbul-konvention auch
zusammenarbeiten und wie werden die
nächsten Schritte da sein
wir brauchen die bundesgesetzliche
Regelung die soll auch enthalten
grundsätzlich eine finanzielle
Absicherung der entsprechenden
Einrichtungen
dazu werde ich natürlich auch mit allen
anderen Ressorts entsprechend sprechen
und ich hatte schon darauf hingewiesen
dass es noch die eine oder andere
ergänzungsnotwendigkeit gibt bei der
nationalen Umsetzung da ist dann wohl
Konvention und da ist natürlich
insbesondere auch das
Bundesjustizministerium gefragt und auch
das Bundesinnenministerium
eine weitere Frage zu diesem Thema Frau
von Storch aus der afd-fraktion
ja vielen Dank
Gewalt gegen Frauen das ist der Inhalt
der istanbul-konvention jeder Mensch auf
der Welt ist gegen Gewalt gegen Frauen
aber nicht jeder Mensch auf der weltweis
möglicherweise was mit Frau gemeint ist
und danach frage ich immer Leute an den
Teil immer erläuternden Bericht zu der
Konvention stehen zweierlei Dinge drin
im Zusammenhang mit dem vorliegenden
Übereinkommen versiert der Begriff
Geschlecht auf den beiden Geschlechtern
männlich und weiblich Mann und Frau
steht im erläuternden Teil des Berichtes
und im Widerspruch dazu steht später im
Sinne dieser Definition wurde der
Begriff Geschlecht nicht als Synonym der
in diesem Übereinkommen verwendeten
Begriffe Frau und Mann gedacht insofern
ist die Konvention hier
erklärungsbedürftig meine Frage ist
welche Interpretation der Definition von
Frau legen Sie der Konventionen zugrunde
1 biologisches Geschlecht Chromosomen
xx2 juristische Definitionen steht in
Deutschland aktuell rechtlich der Fall
ist der Staat kann das anders regeln
oder drei jeder entscheidet was er gerne
möchte so wie das hier in Deutschland ja
auf jeden Fall hier im Hause praktiziert
wird jeder kann sein Geschlecht selbst
bestimmen wenn man das nicht anerkennt
gibt es ein riesen eh klar 1 2 oder 3
also ich finde die istanbul-konvention
ist da sehr stimmig sie sagt eben ganz
klar eine Frau ist eine Person
weiblichen Geschlechts sie haben ja dann
in den späteren Ausführungen bisschen
darauf hingewiesen wird irgendwie dass
sie das eins zu eins nur auf das
biologische Geschlecht beziehen so das
ist aber nicht die Definition der
istanbul-konvention und das ist auch
nicht die Definition dieser
Bundesregierung das ist auch nicht die
Definition der rechtlichen Lage in
Deutschland
[Musik]
haben sie noch eine Nachfrage zu diesem
Thema
nein
dann würde ich in die normale Frage
Liste weitergehen wenn ich zu diesem
Thema kann weitere Nachfrage habe dann
ist jetzt die Kollegin Heidi Reicheneck
aus der Fraktion die Linken dran
vielen Dank ich würde gerne mal auf ein
anderes Thema zu sprechen kommen sie
wissen ja wie wir alle im Haus dass die
Schlangen vor den Tafeln immer länger
werden das stehen auch immer mehr Kinder
wir haben jetzt neulich vom
Kinderhilfswerk der Arche gehört dass da
verzweifelte Eltern anrufen weil schon
Mitte des Monats kein Essen mehr im
Kühlschrank ist es steht zu befürchten
dass viele Kinder zu Hause jetzt frieren
weil die Nebenkosten einfach nicht
gedeckt werden können und im Endeffekt
ist auch die Armutsquote von Kindern in
Deutschland seit Jahren leider nicht
gesunken sondern steigt das ist jetzt
auch alles nichts neues und deswegen
freue ich mich sehr dass sie so eine
starke befürworterung der
Kinderförderung der Kindergrundsicherung
sind das wird aber ja noch eine ganze
Weile dauern so und bis dahin haben wir
jetzt ein Kinder so vorzuschlag von
grandiosen 20 Euro eine kleine Erhöhung
beim Kindergeld und deswegen möchte ich
sie als Ministerin und auch für Ihr Haus
Fragen ist das in ihren Augen
ausreichend was die Regierung da bisher
geleistet hat oder werden sie sich dafür
einsetzen dass da noch weitere Schritte
folgen bis es endlich eine
Kindergrundsicherung geben wird
also ich finde diese Bundesregierung hat
mit dem ersten zweiten und dritten
entlassungspaket wirklich relevantes
Geld zur Verfügung gestellt auch
insbesondere für die die es besonders
nötig haben ich erlebe ich erlebe das
auch ja dass die Schlangen länger werden
ich bin auch Schirmherrin übrigens in
der Tafel auch von daher ist mir das
noch mal zusätzlich
besonders bekannt und besonderes
Anliegen und deswegen sind wir eben gut
beraten als Bundesregierung zielgenau zu
entlasten und das haben wir auch getan
ich habe es bereits in meinem
Eingangsstatement gesagt weil es mir
ebenso wichtig ist es gibt ja nicht nur
das zusätzliche Kindergeld sondern auch
der Hartz-IV-Satz mit der Reform zum
Bürgergeld wird auch für die Kinder
angehoben deutlich angehoben über 11
Prozent und zusätzlich wird es ja auch
die Erhöhung des Kinderzuschlags geben
ich habe davon gesprochen das Thema
wohngeldreform das heißt und das Thema
energiepreispauschale wir arbeiten ja
auch mit Hochdruck noch mal dran an dem
Thema strompreisbremse und auch an der
Frage wie es geht mit dem Gaspreisen
weiter so das Gesamtpaket muss stimmen
ich kann nur sagen die Bundesregierung
sieht das ich sehe das wir arbeiten
daran wir haben glaube ich etliches auf
den Weg gebracht ich glaube für den
Moment ist das auch erstmal gut wenn wir
die aktuellen Fragen noch zusätzlich
lösen und dann werden wir schauen wie es
über den Winter geht ich bin jedenfalls
jemand der auf jeden Fall immer
ansprechbar ist wenn es zusätzlich
Probleme gibt dann auch diese
zusätzlichen Probleme anzugehen und zu
lösen
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
würde ich gerne noch mal konkreter zur
Kindergrundsicherung Nachfragen also ich
weiß es ist natürlich ein Prozess der
hätte in unseren Augen durchaus ein
bisschen ambitionierter und schneller
stattfinden können nun gibt es
Berechnungen der Personalräte der
Jobcenter die sich mal die Konzepte von
SPD und grün angeschaut haben und da an
Fallbeispielen festgestellt haben dass
zum Beispiel einer alleinerziehende
Mutter oder eine Familie mit drei
Kindern am Ende mit den Kindern
sicherungskonzepten deutlich weniger hat
als durch die jetzigen Sozialleistungen
vom Konzept der FDP fange ich gar nicht
erst an werden Sie sicherstellen dass
dann am Ende eine Kindergrundsicherung
bei den Diskussionen herauskommt die
auch wirklich die Bedarfe der Kinder-
und Jugendlichen deckt
das ist jedenfalls der Anspruch deswegen
gibt es ja verschiedene Arbeitsgruppen
in diesem Zusammenhang die er
interministeriell arbeiten unter anderem
ist ja auch verankert dass das so zu
kulturelle Existenzminimum berechnet
wird und dann einfließen soll aber wir
sind derzeit in den entsprechenden
Beratungen ich würde es auch gerne
schneller haben aber es ist eben einfach
tatsächlich eine komplexe Angelegenheit
ich kann Ihnen aber zusagen dass mein
klares Ziel ist dass wir Ende diesen
Jahres Anfang nächsten Jahres Eckpunkte
zu Kindergrundsicherung vorstellen
können
ich habe weitere Nachfragen zu diesem
Thema aus der cdu/csu-fraktion die
Kollegin Wulff
Frau Bär muss noch warten
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Frau Ministerin sie haben uns
jetzt schon einen Zeitplan zur
Kindergrundsicherung skizziert mich
würde aber noch mal interessieren
angesichts der Preisentwicklung die wir
derzeit haben die Inflation die
Energiepreisentwicklung wie wollen Sie
denn sicherstellen dass das Geld was sie
veranschlagen was sie an die Haushalte
geht tatsächlich auch für die Kinder und
die Bedarfe der Kinder dann ausgegeben
wird und bei den Kindern tatsächlich
auch ankommt und nicht im allgemeinen
Haushalt untergeht
meiner Leben ist das dass derzeit
wirklich nicht die Zeit ist gerade bei
denen die es besonders brauchen
irgendwelche Dinge wegzulegen das Thema
Kinderarmut das eben jedes fünfte Kind
in Deutschland in Armut aufwachsen muss
und dass das nicht okay das ist
eigentlich eine Schande ist dass glaube
ich hat sich inzwischen deutlich
verbreitet aber Moment reden wenn ich
davon dass es darum geht ob man
zusätzliche Buntstifte kriegt oder ein
gebrauchte Schuhe oder andere Schuhe
tragen muss im Moment reden wir davon
dass die Kühlschränke leer sind wir
reden nicht über schlechte Ernährung
sondern wir reden über zu wenig
Ernährung das ist die Situation und
dieser Situation
zu insinuieren ja dass der
Hartz iv-satz die Überführung von Hartz
IV in Bürgergeld und die Steigerung um
knapp 12 Prozent womöglich drauf gehen
könnte für irgendetwas anderes weil die
Eltern sich nicht um ihre Kinder kümmern
das finde ich ehrlich gesagt nicht okay
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
vielen Dank frau Präsidentin ich möchte
das rückweisen dass ich hier das in
irgendeiner Weise suggeriert habe
sondern ich habe nur noch mal
hingewiesen auf die allgemeine Situation
von Familien die in Armut leben und das
ist tatsächlich ein wichtiges Thema auch
in meinem Wahlkreis sind sehr viele
Kinder tatsächlich von Armut betroffen
und deshalb spielt bei mir das Paket zur
Bildung und Teilhabe tatsächlich eine
sehr große Rolle und wird also wir haben
Schätzungen etwa über 200
sozialpädagogische Stellen werden aus
diesem Paket finanziert und kommt direkt
Kindern die in Armut leben zugute meine
Frage daher an sie dann
Koalitionsvertrag steht das auch Teile
des Bildung und teilhabepaketes in der
Kindergrundsicherung aufgehen sollen wie
wollen Sie sicherstellen dass diese
bildungsleistungs für Kinder die in
Armut leben weiterhin bei den Kindern
ankommt und dass die
Kindergrundsicherung nicht zur
bildungsbremse auf der anderen Seite
wird
wenn sie sich so gut auskennen mit dem
Bildungs- und teilhabepaket dann wissen
sie dass ein Viertel des Bildungszentrum
teilhabepakets nach wie vor versickert
in bürokratischen Strukturen und auch
unter anderem deswegen wollen wir es
eben im überführen in die Kinder
Grundsicherung jedenfalls das was in
geldleistungsteil angeht das was die
Kommunen bekommen das ist etwas wo wir
auch der Meinung sind sehr
wahrscheinlich dass das bestehen bleiben
wird aber in der Tat dieses
bürokratische Monster will uns ein
teilhabepaket einer ehemaligen
Familienministerin oder
Arbeitsministerin das ist etwas was ich
jedenfalls nicht sinnvoll finde
vorzuführen
nächste Nachfrage zum Thema Frau Bär
ja vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin Frau
Ministerin mich würde noch mal beim
Thema Finanzen und Kinder ganz besonders
interessieren was sie jetzt auch für
Lösungen anbieten weil Kinder
Grundsicherung dass es immer das
Schlagwort was kommt bei allen
Vorschlägen die wir machen heißt immer
dafür haben wir doch dann die Kinder
Grundsicherung nur wie gesagt dann haben
wir sie vielleicht irgendwann und ich
sage jetzt schon stand heute dass ich
noch nicht davon überzeugt bin dass sie
dieses große Paket wirklich hinbekommen
werden bei den vielen Ministerien die
auch da beteiligt sind und bei dem
Eindruck den wir haben der wenig
ambitioniert ist meine konkrete Frage
ist was machen sie jetzt besonders für
kinderreiche Familien wir haben sie eine
Diskussion ja erlebt dass irgendwie für
diese Regierung ab dem dritten Kind
offensichtlich Familien nicht mehr
existieren deswegen meine ganz konkrete
Frage wir helfen sie jetzt in der
Energiekrise in der Finanzkrise Familien
mit mehr als zwei Kindern was tun Sie
konkret für kinderreiche Familien die
ganz besonders von Armut betroffen sind
haben wir ihn nicht bekannt dass es fürs
erste zweite dritte Kind die 237 Euro
gibt und das ist aber für das vierte
Kind nicht weniger sondern 250 Euro gibt
und auch für das fünfte und sechste von
daher denkt diese Bundesregierung an
Familien und auch an kinderreiche
Familien ansonsten ist es aber so dass
ich schon finde jedes Kind sollte dem
Staat auch gleich viel wert sein und
darüber hinaus sollten eben die Familien
die
einkommensschwächer sind die bedürftiger
sind eben mehr Unterstützung bekommen
und nicht andersherum und das ist genau
das was die Bundesregierung tut deswegen
erhöhen wir nicht nur das Kindergeld
sondern wir verbessern auch den
Kinderzuschlag auf mindestens 250 Euro
wir erhöhen den kinderregelsatz wir
machen zusätzlich etwas beim Wohngeld
weiten deutlich den Bereich der
Empfängerinnen und der möglichen
BezieherInnen aus auf zwei Millionen
Haushalte ich kann hier noch mal einfach
darauf hinweisen es lohnt sich wirklich
sich anzuschauen wie man
wohngeldberechtigt sein kann viele von
ihnen werden jetzt inzwischen die
Möglichkeit haben auch in diesen Bezug
zu kommen es lohnt entsprechende Anträge
zu stellen und zusätzlich wissen sie
gibt es den dass die
energiepreispauschale die eben auch
gezielt in diesen Familien und diesen
diesen Haushalten ankommt es gibt ein
großes Gesamtpaket das gezielt für
Familien und Kinder wirkt und das lasse
ich mich von ihnen auch nicht kaputt
reden
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen also
wir sind so konstruktiv dass wir nichts
kaputt reden wollen wir setzen uns
einfach für die Belange von Kindern an
und deswegen nochmal die Nachfrage wie
schaut es eigentlich aus mit dem
Austausch mit ihren Kolleginnen ganz
konkret auch wie sind sie im Austausch
mit der
bundesbauministerin weil wir natürlich
eine sehr sehr niedrige Eigentumsquote
im Land haben die niedrigste mit in
Europa da ist meine Frage wie wollen
sich überhaupt Familienessen noch
leisten auch ein Haus zu bauen oder sich
eine Wohnung anzuschaffen wie sind da
ihre Gespräche damit überhaupt auch
gerade diejenigen mit Kindern die sich
ein Nest bauen wollen das überhaupt in
Deutschland im Jahr 2022 noch
ermöglichen können
sehr geehrte Frau Abgeordnete ich habe
vollstes Verständnis für alle Familien
die sich ein Nest bauen wollen
das aber jetzt sie insbesondere die
Familien als bedürftig erklären die sich
keine Eigentumswohnung leisten können da
würde ich doch etwas anders
differenzieren und würde sagen wir
sollten uns doch stärker konzentrieren
auf diejenigen die jetzt wirklich mit
dem Rücken zur Wand stehen und deswegen
finde ich die Prioritätenliste wie sie
die Bundesregierung gemacht hat richtig
jetzt geht es tatsächlich darum dass
diejenigen die die Miete nicht mehr
zahlen können dass die eine
entsprechende Unterstützung bekommen und
deswegen unter anderem hat das Kabinett
heute die wohngeldreform beschlossen die
eben sicherstellt nicht nur dass ein
größeren deutlich größeren
Adressatenkreis gibt sondern dass damit
auch sichergestellt wird dass man eben
nur maximal 40 Prozent was auch schon
sehr sehr viel ist das Einkommens für
Miete bezahlen muss dass derzeit ins
teilweise 50 und mehr Prozent die
haushaltevermieten bezahlen müssen das
geht definitiv nicht deswegen finde ich
es einen großen Schritt
wohngeldreform auf den Weg bringen
ich habe zu diesem Thema jetzt noch zwei
Nachfrage
die werde ich jetzt auch noch zulassen
und dann werde ich die regierungsbefang
etwas verlängern müssen oder der Kollege
oder die Kollegin die nach mir hier
sitzt weil wir einmal die FDP noch in
dieser einfragerunde in der ersten
noch zu noch zulassen und die nächste
Nachfrage zum Thema
Kindergrundsicherung ist aus der
afd-fraktion Frau harder Kühnel
ja Frau Bundesministerin die
Bundesregierung hat ja diese sagenhafte
Kindergelderhöhung von 18 Euro für das
erste und zweite Kind beschlossen auf
für 2023 wirklich großzügige 12 Euro für
das dritte Kind vorgesehen sowie diese
leichte Erhöhung des Kinderzuschlags mit
diesen Almosen kann sich die Regierung
hier zwar als Wohltäter aufspielen was
sie auch gerade getan haben aber
vergessen wir nicht diese die gerade
durch die Politik der ampelregierung
verursachten Explosionen auf dem Energie
und bei den Lebenshaltungskosten fressen
diese moderaten Kindergelderhöhung etc
mehrfach auf diese mini-zahlung wirken
also nichts wenn man für Energie einen
mehrfaches dieser Summen aufwenden muss
also inwieweit beabsichtigen Sie hier
eine kurzfristige und wirkliche
Nachbesserung um familienzügiger und
angemessener zu unterstützen
werte Abgeordnete die Kindergelderhöhung
und auch die anderen Erhöhungen liegen
über der derzeitigen Inflationsrate und
die Entwicklung der Energiepreise werden
ja durch zusätzliche Maßnahmen abgedeckt
unter anderem wird ja auch in dieser
Woche noch mal intensiv darum gerungen
wie sich
wie das Thema Gaspreise geregelt werden
soll und in diesem Gesamtpaket bin ich
tatsächlich sehr sehr zuversichtlich
dass Familien und insbesondere Familien
mit weniger Geld gut über diesen Winter
kommen weil wie gesagt die Aufstockung
ist erstmal über der Inflationsrate und
zu den Energiepreisen gibt es weitere
Maßnahmen und im Gesamtpaket macht das
alles sehr viel Sinn und hofft klappt
hoffentlich dass wir alle gut über den
Winter kommen wenn das Wetter mitspielt
genau und vor allem da können Sie sich
gerne noch mal mit den Familien
unterhalten wenn die die ersten
Abschlagszahlungen auf ihre
Stromrechnung bekommen aber was sie vor
allem beachten müssen sie haben es
vorher selber erwähnt die Bertelsmann
Stiftung hat eine Studie herausgegeben
dass jedes fünfte Kind in Deutschland in
Armut lebt das heißt 2,8 Millionen
Jugend wenn Kinder unter 18 Leben in
Armut und durch die verantwortungslose
Energie- und Wirtschaftspolitik der
Ampel verschärft sich diese Schieflage
zusätzlich und ganz besonders bis zum
nächsten Frühjahr welches ganz konkrete
Konzept haben sie die Kinderarmut
langfristig zu begegnen mit diesen
moderaten Erhöhungen beim Kindergeld und
bei Kinderzuschlag sowie der
Einordnungen anderen Sozialleistungen
kann es ja wohl nicht bleiben
sehr geehrter Abgeordnete ihre
Einschätzungen zur Arbeit dieser
Bundesregierung teile ich ausdrücklich
nicht das ist natürlich darauf verweisen
dass wir mit Hochdruck an der Einführung
der Kindergrundsicherung arbeiten die
eben mehr ist als die Einzelteile des
bisherigen Systems und die Eckpunkte
dazu werden
spätestens Anfang kommenden Jahres
vorliegen dann können sie sich
entsprechend darüber noch ein Bild
machen ansonsten ist der klare Fahrplan
dass wir bis zum bis zum vierten Quartal
im kommenden Jahr ein Gesetzesentwurf
vorlegen und dass wir dann auch
tatsächlich gemeinsam noch erleben
werden die sind Legislaturperiode dass
die Kindergrundsicherung bei den
Familien diesem Land ankommt weil sie
2025 ausgezahlt wird
so vielen Dank dann habe ich eine
Fragestellung aus der Fraktion mit 90
grünen wenn es richtig ist das so ein
Zettel steht ist es Niederschlag
herr Präsident Frau Ministerin ich
möchte noch mal zurückkommen auf das
Vorurteil das
ärmere Familien wenn dort mehr Geld
reinkommt dieses Geld den Kindern nicht
zu Gute kommt ich möchte fragen auch
wenn ich davon ausgehe dass das so ist
ob Ihnen die Bertelsmann Studie bekannt
ist die eben genau diese Vorurteile
widerlegt die sagt wenn mehr Geld in den
Familien ist dann steigt die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass Kinder eine
Kindertageseinrichtung besuchen aber
auch die Musikschule den Sportverein die
also belegt dass mehr Geld in arme
Familien mehr Teilhabe bei den Kindern
bedeutet und dann basierend auf diesen
Erkenntnissen möchte ich Sie fragen was
glauben Sie Frau Ministerin dass der
Paradigmenwechsel den die
Kindergrundsicherung mit sich bringen
wird für Auswirkungen haben wird für
eben diese Familien
sehr geehrter Frau
sehr geehrte Frau Star
sie haben völlig recht es ist diese eine
Studie aber auch alle Studien haben
bisher gezeigt dass dieses sich
hartnäckig haltende Vorurteile wirklich
jeglicher fachlicher Begründung entbehrt
umso wichtiger ist es dass auch immer
noch wieder breiter und deutlicher
bekannt zu machen und mit der
Kindergrundsicherung
könnte es eben dann tatsächlich gelingen
dass es ein freieres ein freieres mit
der entsprechenden existenziellen
Absicherung gibt es auch mehr
Möglichkeiten zu Teilhabe es ist ja eben
so dass das Armut eben ja nicht nur in
materielles Problem ist sondern Armut
ist insgesamt etwas womit nicht und die
Chancengerechtigkeit sinkt sondern für
jedes einzelne Kind bedeutet es erstmal
diese Gesellschaft will mich nicht ich
habe immer alles für mich ist schwerer
und alles ist schwieriger und das hat
von Anfang an furchtbare psychosoziale
Wirkungen die sich dann auch im Leben
kaum dann komplett aufholen lassen und
deswegen ist es ganz wichtig dass wir
eben ein Fünftel unserer Kinder und
Jugendlichen nicht einfach hinten
runterfallen lassen sondern dass wir sie
eben gezielt unterstützen durch die
Kinder Grundsicherung dann werden auch
insgesamt eine freundliche und
kindergerechte Gesellschaft und auch das
täte uns allen gut
vielen Dank Frau Ministerin keine
weiteren Nachfrage dann ist noch von der
FDP-Fraktion glaube ich der Kollege Nico
tippelt dann
so jetzt sehr geehrte Frau Ministerin
dann würde ich mich bei Ihnen nach den
digitalen Antragsverfahren von
Familienleistung erkundigen Leistungen
die Bürger sehr häufig beantragen sind
etwa die Anmeldung bei der Gemeinde die
Beantragung von Elterngeld des
Mutterschaftsgeldes Kindergeld die
Anmeldung zur Familienversicherung in
der gesetzlichen Krankenversicherung
Meldungen im Zusammenhang mit dem
Mutterschaftsgeld und Mutterschutz
Eltern haben in den ersten Tagen nach
der Geburt ihres Kindes zweifellos
besseres zu tun als ich mit so viel
Bürokratie zu beschäftigen inzwischen
haben ja haben wir ja alle rechtlichen
Hürden beseitigt damit Antragstellung
künftig in einem gemeinsamen digitalen
verfahrener Licht werden können einige
Bundesländer sind hier weiter als andere
Bremen etwa hat eine erfolgreiche App
und ein Verfahren mit dem klingenden
Namen Elfe einfach Leistungen für Eltern
daher meine Frage an Sie wie können wir
bundesweite die bundesweite Umsetzung
eines einheitlichen einfachen und
digitalen Prozesses beschleunigen
sehr geehrte Abgeordneter eine sehr sehr
gute Frage sie wissen wir haben als
Bundesregierung die
digitalstrategie miteinander verabredet
wo wir eben nicht einfach wie früher
Regierung irgendwie einfach neue
Visionen aufgeschrieben haben sondern wo
wir uns miteinander vereinbart haben
eine tatsächliche Dinge abzuarbeiten und
zu ermöglichen und deswegen kann ich zu
all dem was sie da gerade gesagt haben
sagen das ist alles noch in keinem guten
Zustand aber wir arbeiten mit Hochdruck
daran das ermöglicht mir doch mal darauf
hinzuweisen dass bei der
Kindergrundsicherung auch wichtig ist
sozusagen welche materiellen
Bestandteile hat aber das entscheidende
für den Erfolg der Kindergrundsicherung
ist dass wir da Leistung zusammenführen
aber sie vor allen Dingen dann auch
digital ausgezahlt werden soll und auch
dazu Arbeiten laufen die Arbeiten ich
verspreche mir davon tatsächlich einen
entscheidenden qualitativen Unterschied
wenn eben alle die Leistungen möglichst
automatisiert und digital bekommen damit
eben auch all die die bisher
anspruchsberechtigt sind aber das Geld
bei ihnen nicht ankommt weil sie das mit
dem Antragsverfahren so kompliziert und
schwierig finden auch endlich die
Leistung bekommen die sie brauchen
eine Nachfrage Kollege Titel zur
Nachfrage das klingt fantastisch haben
Sie schon eine Vorstellung von der
Zeitschiene oder gibt es da schon so
Überlegungen wo sie sagen da geht's los
oder da passiert was
ich kann Ihnen klar sagen dass dieser
Prozess der der Frage der technischen
Umsetzung wie kann man das digital
machen dass der nicht erst beginnen wird
wenn wir das Gesetz auf den Weg gebracht
haben sondern das läuft derzeit parallel
weil es ist ja einfach sinnig wenn man
nicht erst ein Gesetz machen hinterher
feststellt das Gesetz kann man so nicht
umsetzen sondern dass das eben exakt
parallel läuft damit wir eben dann auch
sehr sehr schnell am Start sind die
Arbeiten dazu laufen
vielen Dank damit beende ich die
regierungsbefragung der Kollege
poppenstedter zurecht bemerkt dass man
15 Minuten über der Zeit das wird jetzt
von der Fragestunden
hatte
besteht Übereinstimmung dann würden wir
in dieser Frage wenn es kein Kind
[Musik]
also mir ist von der Präsidentin Bärbel
Bars mitgeteilt worden die FDP sei die
letzte Fragestellerin dieser Frage da
verfahren wir so dann werden dich jetzt
die regierungsbefragung und rufe
auftragungspunkt 2 Fragestunde die
Fragen auf Drucksache 20 und damit ist
die Befragung der Bundesregierung doch
erstmal beendet Bundestagsvizepräsident
Wolfgang Kubicki hat das jetzt auch noch
mal begründet Lisa Paus die hier eine
gute Stunde den Abgeordneten Rede und
Antwort gestanden hat ja es folgt jetzt
hier im Ablauf dieser Plenarwoche die
Fragestunde
da muss man zu sagen dass die Fragen
jeweils nur schriftlich eingereicht
werden und also dann auch nur hier von
den parlamentarischen Staatssekretären
auf diese schriftliche Frage geantwortet
wird deswegen ist es doch sehr schwierig
das hier zu vermitteln deswegen gibt es
noch melden wir und wieder zur aktuellen
Stunde gegen 15 Uhr zu den Protesten im
Iran jetzt geht es erstmal weiter mit
meinem Kollegen Michael sein Bonn ich
schreibe mit vielen Dank Jeanette Clark
15 Uhr hören wir uns wieder aus Berlin
wir wollen die Zeit nutzen diese Woche
ist in Fulda die Deutsche
Bischofskonferenz Herbst Vollversammlung
es geht um den Fortgang des Synodalen
Weges es geht um einen Besuch der
deutschen Bischöfe im November in Rom
beim Papst und es geht um die
Aufarbeitung des sexuellen Missbrauchs
zur weiteren